The Joe Rogan Experience I made a video
once I said this is the best Christmas
gift you could possibly get a kid
because with it you can see the same
craters on the moon that Galileo saw
light pollution does not obscure the you
know the planets light pollution does
not make impossible I'm not advocating
for light pollution but I'm just saying
right here in the middle of Austin or in
the middle of San Diego I can see the
exact same things that cause Galileo to
realize that the sun is the center of
the solar system using scientific
reasoning and evidence based on
observation how good are the telescopes
like say if you wanted to look at
Jupiter how much can you say you can you
can see a lot what you can see you can
see the shape that it's that it's a
planet do you know what that word Planet
means or where it derives no so I love
etymology and stop me if I'm nerding out
too much the planet means Wanderer in
Greek wander what is it wandering
against the thick Stars so the thing the
fact that you have names for things you
know I always I always think it's funny
like I'm Jewish and we have a name for
people that aren't Jewish going it's not
an insult it just means it means Nation
actually Israel is a which is a
nation but we like but we're 0.2 percent
of the world's population like what the
hell why are you making up names for
they should make names for you right
right uh but we we have names as
astronomers there's only there are only
five things they could see that would
move in in space and those were the
planets from Mercury Venus obviously
they could see Mars and Jupiter and
Saturn but they couldn't see anything
else so they named those things The
Wanderers and they wandered against the
thick stars now we know the stars do
move and and actually the whole galaxy
moves and potentially we'll get to this
maybe later and maybe the universe in
some sense can be said to be moving uh
in in a vaster landscape called the
Multiverse which we can get to it at a
certain point but uh but the planets you
can see them but what's so important is
what Galileo saw Jimmy if you could show
this would be amazing Galileo in the in
the winter of 1610 in Northern Italy
where he was living
he used a telescope not not any better
than this in fact this might be better
because the glass is better even though
it's a Chinese piece of junk you know I
bought on on eBay but um he mapped he
was able to measure Jupiter and see it
and and hopefully we can see on the
screen and he saw it as a disc
so if you if you want to see planets you
can differentiate them right now by the
fact that they do not scintillate they
do not Sparkle they do not twinkle
twinkle like stars do because they're
extended objects that we can actually
see through the same and different parts
of the atmospheric column that's what
causes scintillation you know like a
sniper rifle they correct for it they
use what's called Adaptive Optics that's
to avoid like the thermal radiation from
the earth like you're shooting something
or elk or whatever at Great distance
there's thermal radiation close to the
ground and then the air is much cooler
and so you get these boundary layers of
the atmosphere that causes differential
refraction which changes the color and
the position of where the deer is and
that's not good right so they have to
correct for that using what's called
Adaptive Optics anyway
um but the the same phenomena happens
for the planets they're so big they're
so close to us they're not bigger than
the star stars are massively bigger than
any of our planets including Jupiter the
biggest planet in the solar system but
because uh they're close to us they
don't appear to be points and only
points will twinkle so if you want to
identify a star versus a plane versus a
planet the planet will be the thing that
doesn't move
and doesn't twinkle that's called
scintillation they do not scintillate
the same way that stars do so what uh
what Galileo did in January of 1610 is
he made a series of observations of the
planet Jupiter he knew exactly where it
was he also invented the tripod he was
the first person these things that we
just take for granted like Joe do you
know that they didn't have clocks back
then there was no clock
right they had Sun dogs but what are you
gonna do at night it was the first clock
so Galileo tried to invent the first
clock it was actually part of a
precursor to the Nobel Prize it was
something called the longitude prize
they offered a prize I don't know if
you've ever done any boating or whatever
but when you're out on the ocean it's
extremely hard to determine what your
longitude is it's easy to find your
latitude you just look for Polaris the
North Star you measure your elevation
that's going to complement where you are
latitudinally on the on the axis going
from South Pole to North Pole on the
Earth but it was impossible to tell
where you are east to west from the
prime meridian unless you had an
accurate way of measuring time
so Galileo was was one of the first
people to try to compete to win this
prize which was worth you know like a
million dollars back then in those days
and he uh tried a couple different ways
to invent time pieces but the one that
he's tried to settle on was this use of
the planet Jupiter's moons Jupiter has
four moons
I came for that look Joe I came for that
well as just I finally I can die happy
right I got the look Jupiter has four
moons and you can see them with this
telescope and I'm going to give this as
a gift to you for that little tiny one
you can see it yeah if you know if
Jupiter's out you know where to look and
the economy is a little bit how much
power is that one this one this one's
about 12 15 power so you could do it
with 15 binoculars yep yeah easily yeah
you'll see what you'll see these four
moons but I wonder if um if Jamie if you
could find find something that wasn't
great if you look up um a Starry
Messenger
Starry Messenger Galileo sketch Jupiter
so what Galileo did is he turned the
telescope to the moon for the in 1609
and then 1610
there they are Jamie on the right with
those Stars
look at that illustration of Galileo
that's his handwritten and I've seen a
friend of mine owns this copy a first
edition of these books and you're
looking at it and actually a first
edition the actual copy that he wrote
not only that yeah the first edition but
it has his handwriting on it and pencil
whoa it's insane oh my God that's got to
be worth a billion dollars oh it's it's
Jamie could you please go back to that
those illustrations
stuff oh wow so I just I couldn't tell
what this was
again imagine having a piece of paper
that that guy wrote on can you imagine
it so this is uh yeah so this is a
depiction of him showing segali as a guy
at the beard looking down
um like Andrew huberman at the guy with
the uh
a beautiful chiseled beard that's right
muscular uh so he's showing this
Venetian senators and those because they
were in charge of the military budget so
even back then there was a scientific
military connection that he realized
because he because Galileo was a kind of
a cad he had a bunch of uh Mistresses he
had some illegitimate children how dare
you Galileo he had a support okay not be
pure he had to support his uh his
brother who's kind of a no good Nick but
anyway the sketches in the in the lower
right show the planet and as you will
see it with this telescope I'll let you
know when it comes out and those four
little dots there was an image a couple
of um Pages back Jamie that showed the
planet as a disc and then there are four
stars and if you go back one I'll I'll
point it out to you yeah see that thing
in the lower right Jamie it's a
Pinterest thing I don't know if that's
the best yeah click on that so here's a
couple of see it says January well it's
hard to say it's January
um 1610 that's Galileo's handwriting and
ionis is like Jupiter okay so he had
handwriting oh I know yeah I always
thought people back then just wrote
perfectly with feathers who knew how to
read it that's a good point that's a
very good point he's got like a doctor's
handwriting exactly so this is his first
major book and um in the upper uh left
you see the sketch of the Moon with
these giant craters on it that crater
yeah so if you go back so click on that
channel that's his sketch that's his
sketch of the Moon through this
telescope essentially okay now the
interesting thing is see that big crater
that doesn't exist really it doesn't the
one on the top no the one on the bottom
that one doesn't exist does not exist
now why is it there he was a smart guy
he wasn't like he he was an artist too
by the way his father of vicenzo was a
beautiful musician a well-known musician
he was a sketch I mean it's hand-drawn
because Joe
he wanted to convey not only what it
looked like but how it felt
hmm he was conveying and when you see it
you'll feel like it's like that big but
if you actually measure it's about 10
times smaller than that but oh so he
just made it larger than it really is to
emphasize it and what's so cool about
that if you want to know uh you've had
on like my friend Sean Caroline he
talked about the Higgs boson when he was
on the first time
um if you want to feel what it was like
to discover the Higgs boson you need 10
to 20 billion euros and you need a Large
Hadron Collider okay good luck
um I don't know if Spotify is gonna you
know up there but uh but the uh but the
feeling that Galileo had you can have
that tonight you can feel what it's like
to see things for the first time in
human history because it's your own
history you're experiencing it for the
first time there's no other scientific
tool nothing even the microscope it's
not the same viscerally you will be
connected to Galileo 400 years ago
feeling he was terrified when he saw
those pictures of those dots he realized
what he was looking at was not just like
some stars that happened to be next to
Jupiter he realized he discovered
another solar system a system in which
there was a massive gravitating object
Jupiter and around it were orbiting
satellites or orbiting moons around it
today they're called the Galilean
satellites he actually named them after
his benefactor those patrons the medicis
who were the richest you know people in
in that part of Northern Italy so he
named he was clever right he was trying
to Curry favor or maybe this would be
like if we named the uh the you know
whatever the Higgs boson we named that
after you know the European uh you know
equivalent the IRS right right he was
kind of a kiss hand a kiss-up you know
it's always sycophant but it had to save
his life and he needed money and
something right but when he drew that he
realized the wait a second the Bible and
all teaching here which of four said
there is only one Center to the solar
system and and it's the Earth not the
sun this is called geocentrism everybody
believed that Aristotle uh or Plato
everybody had believed that for a long
time because it said it was natural that
heavy thing should fall towards a center
and the center that everything seemed to
fall towards was the center of the Earth
or the Earth itself therefore the Earth
must be the center of the universe
remember the solar system was the
universe for a long time then for an
equally long time almost the Galaxy was
the whole universe and now there's the
universe and maybe the Multiverse that
we'll talk about so this was just
incredible realization to him imagine
like you come upon this thing and you
realize you're the first person in human
history ever to feel that is there any
uh documentation of his struggle with
trying to convey these ideas to people
that had very strong religious beliefs
yeah because obviously it turned out to
be a catastrophe for him that's right
but what did he did he convey in his
writing the frustration that he had he
was he's such a fascinating person I
always like provocative statement that
like we don't need English departments
we should just teach like physics and
astronomy because some of the great
scientists of History men and women were
tremendous orators they were tremendous
writers and they could convey things
through the written word that was pure
Artistry and Mastery and Galileo would
say things like I do not believe that
the same God who has given us senses to
understand the world would require that
we not use that on butchering the quote
not use them in order to better
understand it he would write things that
he had discovered things you know only
as a way to open a portal into the
universe such that mind's more astute
than mine may be able to walk through
this portal and it was being a little
falsely humble but Newton was the same
way Newton would write as a great order
so you can learn a lot from scientific
writing so therefore if you only had to
choose one thing I would take the books
of Galileo in this geocentric version of
the universe that they've how how is it
written in the Bible like how do they
describe it's actually you know the
atheist so I I I call myself a
practicing agnostic which I can Define
later if you like but you had on my
friend Stephen C Meyer which is you know
partially the reason that I'm here I
think um but uh but to have the
discussion about you know the influence
of religion on science and he made the
claim that without religion we wouldn't
have science on this show a couple weeks
ago in other words we wouldn't have the
tradition that we can that the world is
intelligible it's not the capricious
will of God's you know uh playing with
human beings as Greeks and and others
hadn't identified
um so the uh the notion of you know how
religious a scientist could be or how
religion impacted him was very clear he
would say he was a very religious person
in fact two of his daughters were nuns
and and because of his
um you know I always say like imagine
we're living in a time where someone
like Anthony fauci or you know Francis
Collins or somebody that they had they
were not all only the scientists the
expert scientists say but they also
control the government in other words
the most powerful force on Earth at that
time at least where Galileo is was the
Vatican he never left Italy he never
left Italy didn't exist back then by the
way they were only city-states right
Tuscany and Venice and Rome and so forth
but the the notion it was a Catholic you
know band of jurisdiction and Catholic
church had sway over that part of Italy
and Tuscany where he was he was very
religious
um but he he thought that he could say
things like if he proved that something
scientifically was true he didn't
understand why that couldn't be part of
the religious Canon so he was surprised
in other words he he felt that the
signature of God is truth so if he
discovered truth it wouldn't be a
problem for the it would be friends but
I argued back then it was kind of
threatening like if you started having a
bunch of people say oh the Bible's wrong
we've been misled and they're the
government not just scientific Authority
they're the government
um it could lead I'm not saying it's
good but it could lead them to want to
suppress that right because it could
lead to insurrections it could lead to
whatever
um and and rebellions and that could be
perceived as very threatening to the
state